hey thank you 633 we do start with the
developing story the arrest of a star
nfl running back alvin kamara here in
las vegas the new orleans saint arrested
after playing in the pro bowl he is
expected in court today facing felony
charges after an incident at a nightclub
bianca holman joining us live in the
newsroom to explain bianca is he still
in jail
good morning while the 2017 nfl
offensive rookie of the year posted 5
thousand dollars bail he's no longer in
custody this after being booked on a
charge of battery resulting in
substantial bodily harm which is a
felony after playing and making four
catches for 23 yards in sunday's pro
bowl camaro was arrested and taken to
clark county detention center police say
the fight happened inside a nightclub
the victim named camara as the suspect
on saturday after they were called to
the hospital just before 6 p-m the
player's representative nor the saints
have responded publicly to this
situation yet so the player is due in
court this afternoon we will have an
update later when that happens bianca
holman live local now